hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the very
first round of the newly started cter
Masters 2023 it is Magnus Carlson versus
Indian International Master shrihari
maybe I'm pronouncing that wrong if I am
do correct me in the comment section and
U well it's a classical tournament so of
course we are going to enjoy a lot of um
great classical chess and the tournament
features some very strong players like
former world champion Magnus Carlson
hiar Nakamura Anish giri n Abdus of GES
arjuni param maku and so on the list is
really great and as it's a classical
event it's a one and a half hour per
player uh plus you get additional time
30 minutes after 40 moves have been
played so uh let's check it out the
tournament price fund is
$110,000 uh I haven't checked how much
for the first place but uh you know it's
it's obvious obviously quite a lot as
they uh uh you know received such a fine
lineup so let's check it out this game
is basically a bar fight that Shari or
SAR I think it's Shari challenges Magnus
to and Magnus accepts the challenge to
abar fight so let's check it out Magnus
opens with C4 he goes for the English
opening and we have C6 this is basically
an invitation uh to transpose into the
pawn of attack of the caroan sort of the
accelerated version but we have D4 by
Magnus and now Pawn to D5 transposing
into the SLO defense Knight to F3 and
now Knight to F6 with have Pawn to G3 um
Magnus as usual getting ready to fian to
his light Square bishop and Bishop to F5
we have Knight to C3 and E6 so very
standard stuff here uh you get your
light Square Bishop out of the cage and
then you put your pawns on light Square
so you don't care if the Knight trades
itself for the bishop because you will
have a dark Square Bishop to go in
between those um pawns and light squares
so Magnus does Go For That Knight to H4
and now de captures on C4 you could also
go for something like Bishop to E4 first
going after the Rook uh White would
challenge the bishop and once the bishop
uh moves even something like Queen to B3
can be played going after
B7 so it's uh also very standard stuff
uh but in the game sari went for uh D
captures on C4 we have Knight captures
on F5 and now e captures on F5 and here
okay Magnus is down a pawn but sari has
a double set of double pawns uh so well
it can be useful but also it looks uh
looks a bit weird uh we have Pawn E3 by
Magnus and now Bishop to D6 now if you
want to uh defend your Pawn with Pawn to
B5 it's you know from the Catland that
it's a bit too much too optimistic uh
for example Bishop G2 already looking
very strong and if B4 you can even throw
in a nice Knight to E2 then you're going
to collect the pawns here Queen C2 and
black will just be in um a lot of
problems so it's best just to give back
material Bishop to D6 and Magnus uh wins
the pawn back so Bishop captures on C4
uh castles and now Queen to F3 putting
pressure on the F5 pawn and just Pawn to
G6 okay very nicely done Pawn to H3 and
now there is a game where C5 was played
but here we have Queen to E7 and it is
now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so okay Magnus
continues with castles and now Ponta H5
not allowing G4 to be played Magnus
plays Rook to E1 he wants to play Pawn
to E4 as he now will control it with
Queen rook and Knight and um shiari
stops it he plays Knight to E4 we have
Pawn to G4 by Magnus and now H captures
on G4 now we could check out a line for
example Pawn to B5 to attack the bishop
Bishop D3 and Knight G5 to attack the
queen but now Queen G2 and it looks very
dangerous for white as well but it's
actually perfectly fine for example F
captures H captures and now the problem
is yes you could go for something like
H4 but now Pawn to E4 preparing Pawn to
E5 then the bishop Comes Alive you will
win this pawn and the white will have a
much better position and the problem
with H3 is that white very gladly trades
Queens captures captures captures
captures and now King captures on G2
it's actually white who will be up upon
at the end of this variation with a very
strong Center and just a very very nice
game a much better game of course so
after G4 uh we have H captures and G4 H
captures and now uh Bishop to B4 now you
you you could go for Knight captures and
C3 and maybe you even should and after B
captures offer offer a queen trade uh
but even a queen trade will not be that
spectacular for black for example captus
captus and capis now E4 is coming uh
it's equal material but sorry not even
equal material magnets would be down
upon but he would have the very strong
Bishop pair and again this would um uh
of course favor white so here we have
Bishop to B4 putting pressure on the
Knight here uh it's um not the not the
cleanest way to play but uh uh it's
definitely comes with a threat so Magnus
goes for G captures on F five we have
Knight captures on C3 and now B captures
on C3 Bishop captures attacks both of
magnus's Rooks and Magnus plays Queen to
G4 now what's the idea behind this Rook
sacrifice well if you take either Rook
uh then it's merely a matter of Queen
captures and G6 as the F Pawn is pinned
and once the king moves Queen to H6 with
check King to G8 and now King H2 uh
there is no defense against Rook to G1
Checkmate so here after this uh Queen to
G4 move King to G7 was played but now
Magnus has one move that is so extremely
strong that it just wins the game on the
spot of course you have to calculate but
it does win the game uh so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
absolute Beast of a move while I give
you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that the Queen and King are in
a very unfavorable position and for
those of of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Pawn to E4 with this move
Magnus continues offering a full Rook or
full Rooks uh and he doesn't care uh
regardless of what black does the
position is just so so winning for white
with this massive Pawn Center and it's
incredible that you can actually attack
like this with your your king wide open
but the problem is and I'm I'm just
going to show you a few lines because
it's a classical game and you know it's
a really nice position let's say you
capture a rook what happens because that
was played in the game so we're not
going to start with that but let's say
uh you don't accept let's say you play
Bishop captures on D4 you hold uh the D5
Pawn you don't really hold it just
Bishop B5 and now after Bishop captures
on E5 you don't go for Pawn to F4 you
actually go for Bishop to G5 you attack
the queen uh sorry the queen and now
after F6 as it's pretty much your only
move uh now comes Bishop to H6 with
check opening up the uh G Gile for the
queen so if you capture Queen captures
on G6 is Checkmate and if you go up the
board then just Bishop captures on f8
attacks the queen and once the queen
captures King to G2 and there is no
defense against Rook to H1 you could
even play G5 uh doesn't matter Queen to
H5 check King to G7 and now Rook to H1
and there's no stopping Checkmate
because the bishop controls all of the
light squares here so that's one way to
do it another way another way is to
ignore the the Rooks ignore the pawn
maybe play Knight to D7 just try to
bring another Defender into the game uh
then it's a matter of Queen H3 and now
you are going after the H6 Pawn H6
Square so Rook to h8 and now just Queen
captures and C3 so you collect the piece
and you just keep a better position and
okay you do have to be a little bit
careful of course black and threat and
Checkmate but Queen F3 stops that and
once let's say queen H2 check King to F1
and Rook to H3 is played attacking the
White Queen yes looks dangerous but
Bishop F4 black has to trade queens and
white is up a full piece Rook captures
on F3 Bishop captures on H2 you're going
to play G captures and okay uh black is
up a pawn but Magnus would be up a full
piece he would have the bishop pair uh
and a completely winning position so
that's why after Pawn to E4 uh shrihari
said well okay we have to go for The
Rook Bishop captures on A1 was played
but now comes Bishop to G5 that's the
move attacking the queen and there's not
much you can do if you block with F6 now
again Bishop to H6 and it's pretty much
the same variation even maybe a nicer
one because after King moves you can
even play F capture and G6 and there is
no defense against uh uh Pawn to G7 is
just a crushing crushing idea also Queen
to H5 I mean uh with with the
advancement of the of Black's F Pawn uh
and the bishop controlling this diagonal
this is just uh brutal so after Bishop
G5 Queen to B4 was played now attacking
the bishop and threatening The Rook here
with check and now F6 with check we have
King to G8 and now Rook captures on A1
uh there was even a cooler way for
Magnus to finish this and that's King to
G2 sort of sacrificing The Rook on E1
but it is I mean greatly unnecessary I'm
just going to show it because it's
possible and now you play Bishop B3 with
the same threat of Queen captures and G6
and once Black Blocks this you will get
deliver a check King has to go to G8 and
now Queen H6 there is no stopping
Checkmate here so instead Rook captures
an A1 was played by Magnus pretty much
the same thing only you don't you know
give up The Rook for no reason uh Knight
to D7 trying to get rid of the F6 Pawn
but doesn't really work here Magnus just
played Queen to H3 also you could
capture the Knight but I mean there's no
reason to do that Queen to H3 and he was
in this position un move 23 that shihar
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so very nicely done
by Magnus as usual he continues his
winning streak in classical chess um uh
not not a winning streak but a non
losing streak as okay he did win like
maybe his five or four classical games
in a row but then he drew one uh in the
uh for his Club offer spill and uh you
know it wasn't like all the games were
winning but still I mean very impressive
and he's very very close to Breaking
2850 again in classical I think he's
around 2845 2846 so very nicely done and
the reason why there's no defense
against this is that even be even if you
block even if you go after the F6 Pawn
let's say queen to H6 and you win the F6
Pawn you have another problem Queen
captures on G6 and now everything just
Falls King goes here you're going to
pick up this with check you have to give
up the queen and now there's even a very
cool way of finishing this queen to H4
check King to G7 Queen to G5 check King
to H7 and now you even allow your queen
to be skewed because after Rook to G8
sort of winning back material there's
Rook to H1 Checkmate so that I mean
chess is just a lot of fun like that uh
very often after Queen to H3 Shar
resigned and a very nice victory for
Magnus Carlson against this very very
strong um 18yearold World International
master from India like I said he
challenged Magnus to a bar fight Magnus
uh you know picked up the glove accepted
the challenge and he emerged Victorious
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it first game that we are
covering from the cter Masters
tournament uh if you guys have any that
that you've enjoyed do sash suggestion
and I will try to cover it as the the
tournament is played simultaneously with
the US Chess Championship I will of
course try to cover both uh but I will
mostly focus on the the best games uh so
yeah once again really hope you enjoyed
it uh I would like to thank Mr hoody Guy
Peter marinov an anonymous person Roger
Stone and no need to mention my name in
the video for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day